hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome game from round five of the proc
chess festival the masters edition and
in this game with it and fallujah
decided to remind us that chess can
still be very much fun and very much
well interesting even though most of the
games today at least in top-level chess
are endless variations of the rule opus
in the Queens gambit declined this is
one one game where that this is not the
case so without further ado visit with
the white pieces opens with d4 and prior
to going into this round the visit is
the leader of the tournament with three
out of four points alavesa is currently
on two and a half out of out of out of
four so the five pile it is at night of
three Knight to f6
we have c4 and c6 future goes for the
slot defense we have C captures C
captures and Knight to c3 so just
continue in developmental Knights the c6
black does the same ended Bishop to f4
now with a six a taking away the be five
square from blacks pieces and rook to c1
as the this is the only open file on the
board so it makes sense Bishop to f5 and
now III now if it it prefers to develop
the light square bishop as well we have
e 6 and now developing the Bishop to e2
and here there are a couple of moves
that were played in this position Bishop
e7 and d6 are the the most played moves
although there are others Queen to b6 is
a new move by future and it is already
as a move 9 that we have a completely
new game so here whether you want to
keep the pawn or not you have to well
you have to decide whether it's ok to
give it up Queen to b6 there are a lot
of variations where you can get at this
point like that like the poison
variation of the of the Sicilian where
Queen to b6 is played but here even
though it's a completely new position of
it it fairly quickly decides the castle
and they give up the be to pawn Allah
raised a decide to grab it with Queen
capture son b2 and now Knight to a4
attacking the Queen and now Queen to b4
you don't want to overstay our welcome
so Queen to b4 and now comes the the
epic move from the thumbnail a3 now
a3
is requires a lot of calculation problem
is the black king is still in the center
of the board and you might you might to
lose your queen if you like I said
overstay our welcome
for example if Queen captures on a3 with
its plan with Knight the b6 you go after
the rook and yes you will not lose the
exchange because of the bishop on at 4
for example rook to d8 now Bishop to c7
will win the exchange but maybe maybe it
was worth giving up the exchange because
you will have to connect to task pawns
on the Queen side for example 94 we can
trade here characters captures and now
after Queen Queen to a4 check you can
even trade down into an endgame and you
are up of the exchange but you have like
I said to connected passed pawns on the
Queen side definitely better than than
what future decided to do future played
Queen to a5 and like the title suggests
this is move 12 so do your thing
I feel free to pause the video and try
to find the winning move for visit while
I give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who are able to do it
congratulations on finding the only
winning move in the position and it's
not an easy move to find and for those
who just want to enjoy the show its
Queen to b3 so what happens here
well the problem is your b7 point is
under attack you cannot defend it as the
bishop is here you cannot push the
b-pawn because of rook out for some c6
but other than that you really don't
have in any good moves and trying
something like queenside castle doesn't
really do anything because Knight b6
check and the King is out of squares the
bishop covers the dark squares the knife
covers d7 so you would have to give up
your queen here so pretty much the only
thing you can do here is what our
leaders are played and that is b5 saying
that okay you capture my knight on c6
I'm gonna capture your knight on a 4 so
rook characters on c6 by vidit Queen
captures an a4 now offering a queen
trait but Queen to c3 now and again if
you just troubles have only just started
you cannot allow rook to see it's such a
deadly trick for example if Bishop
characters on a3 trying to trying to
Castle kingside this is deadly for
example check characters captures with
checking e7 and now
c7 with check King back to 8 and now 95
will be will be deadly
not not a lot of things you can do to
prevent it if you prevented with with
either Bishop g6 or rook the f8 doesn't
really matter
still Queen to see it check King to e7
and on knights the c6 will be mate you
don't have anywhere to go the bishop
covers the d6 square so you cannot allow
rook the c8 with check so here Volusia
again goes for the strongest move he
plays d5 now the bishop guards the c8
square there is no check here from the
rook
but now Knight characters on e5 so or
grabbing back the pawn and already you
have a beautiful night here on e5 and
here B for trying to give more material
to activate to activate pieces we have
eight characters on b4 and now the
question is whether you play something
or you play Bishop characters and b4 but
your PRS and b4 is a very interesting
move but it's a it's a very difficult
move to decide to actually play for
example if Queen to be two now what do
you play if you Castle now which you can
definitely do look the a1 tribes the
Queen that's the problem now you cannot
escape Bishop covers b5 the rook blocks
the Queen the night covers rook so here
your queen is trapped so that's not
nothing
not you what you can do so after a bit
of character Sun before and let's say we
move the Queen now you have to play
something like Queen to a3 but here you
can just trade characters characters and
now go rook to a1 go after the Bishop
Bishop back to e7 in now rook to c7 the
black ink stays in the center of the
board
and will be very very hard to play this
Bishop to b5 check is coming you cannot
capture because of rook captures an a8
so not probably a winning position for
white but again it was it was definitely
a valiant attempt however future went to
Knight to e4 he went 4-4 the Queen here
and here we did just played Queen to a-1
going into a similar endgame but an even
better one with Queen cat you have to
capture the Queen strapped so Queen
captures on a one rook captures any one
and only now Bishop character son before
not making room for the King to finally
Castle with Luke seek a person ace
captures na6 captures on a6 and here
finally if you lose your castle then but
it will not say to him once again feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the winning idea for visit while I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations unsporting that both the
bishop on b4 and the bishop on a5 r
undefended and when you combine those
two ideas you get the move that with it
played so for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show its Knight to c6 this
move now wins because well like I said
if you if this bishop no longer controls
e7 just 97 check picks up the bishop and
the problem is you don't have a square
that you can move the bishop to to keep
an eye on the d6 square because wherever
you go either characters captures or or
captures so instead you could try Bishop
c8 try and give up two pieces for the
Brooke but not really something
characters characters and characters and
you don't have any any background ideas
here because Rukia doesn't do anything
the night already guards the bishop you
cannot go rook to b8 because the bishop
covers b8 and if you often see it well
the bishop just gobbles it up so not not
much to be done here so instead if you
just tried rook to see it now trying to
create some background issues for
example if captures the rook c1 check
bishop has the block and then well
making some room for your own King but
it could be dangerous maybe if the the
knife comes here maybe the bishop can
come to d3 if the knight moves who knows
white is still winning here but wit it
decides not to give you any chances
so instead after this rook to see it
move he pushes g4 which comes with tempo
and also frees the G to square for
wrecking so you get rid of your
background weaknesses while also
attacking the bishop here so Knights the
c3 was played now with idea of a knight
captures an e2 with Czech but Bishop to
f1 and it was in this position unmoved
24 that ali reza Felucia resigned the
game after having having an excellent
start to the tournament with his had an
even better start of the tournament and
he continues to have an excellence
tournament because he's now won four out
of five with with clear first place but
we're probably going to show at least
one more game tomorrow so we're gonna
check out
standing is them so here he resigned
because you're either losing this bishop
or this bishop so like I said if you
capture on g4 you lose the bishop here
and if for example you try something
else
you try to give up the exchange with
rook captures on c6 rook captures and
Bishop captures on g4 it's still
problematic to do two blacks background
issues for example f3 you try and get
this Bishop away from the defense of the
c8 square Bishop to f5 and now rugby six
again threatening the bishop and now
rook to b8 check so once you move still
rook to b8 and there is no nothing you
can do against Bishop to d6 and black
just loses so really really impressive
game and yeah like the title suggests
unmoved 12 Fallujah was lost and with it
took took the opportunity and he played
it out perfectly so blue in game but it
hope the two of them meet again in the
future as I would very much enjoy seeing
more games like this so that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
think then it's often da ho then it's
often dal Adrian's R :
torkoal stinkiest Geoff grapes and brand
a new house for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the proctors
festival continuing the morphe saga as
soon as I get get the chance and
checking up in your wonderful
suggestions so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your Sunday